this is really the case that never ends
and the face at the center
so know that you're comfortable lying
when it's appropriate yes
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
this is part one of our story on the
mystery and death surrounding one man
over the course of almost 40 years
on december 24 2000 los angeles police
entered the residence of 1527 benedict
canyon drive and discovered the dead
body of 55 year old author susan berman
susan berman
was the daughter of an infamous mobster
named davey berman initial speculation
was that it was a mob hit
berman was shot in the back of the head
susan was afraid of her own
not her own shadow but everybody else's
susan would not allow a stranger into
her home
no way
this is a gunshot wound to her head that
means the killer had to be near her she
had to trust the killer
there was one person in susan berman's
life that she was very close to
i saw this girl looked very very pretty
and i went over and started talking to
her
that man was robert durst the heir to
the renowned durst real estate empire
we would spend a lot of time
together talk with everything
in
common
they both became incredibly loyal to
each other it was them against the world
durst is speaking with the producers of
an hbo documentary entitled the jinx
which aired in 2015. in that same year
durst ends up speaking with an la
prosecutor named john lewin as well
you know susan was trying to reach you
over that summer before she died
and you weren't returning her calls do
you know why
i don't remember any such thing
it's these two interviews that would not
only provide information on susan
berman's death but so much more
in order to understand durst's
connection to berman you have to start
from the beginning with his first wife
kathy mccormick durst
[Music]
of education she had zilch i i guess you
would say i was marrying beneath me or
something like that or she by
most accounts
the early part of the relationship
between robert durst and kathy was
very loving and caring but
as time went on his relationship with
kathy began to be very strained
and was the dominant person in the
marriage
i think she kind of got tired of some of
the
i mean you know she got tired absolutely
he began to become abusive towards her
by 1981 our life was
half arguments fighting slapping pushing
wrestling
during that time kathy went to nursing
school and then to medical school
as she became more independent of durst
he became more controlling and more
violent
i was basically saying get the heck out
and she was afraid but she thought she
could handle him
kathy and robert's relationship came to
a screeching halt on january 31st 1982.
after kathy left a dinner party in
connecticut it's believed she went back
to the home she shared with durst in
south salem new york
kathy then vanished
in fact there have been no confirmed
sightings of her ever since
if you think kathy's okay
if you're trying to figure out what's
wrong with her the first thing you do is
you call
her family and you go hey have you seen
kathy it's just a weird do you see what
seems strange about calling the police
first
i didn't feel like talking to her family
and friends
durst has always maintained that the
last time he saw kathy he drove her that
night to the train station in south
salem where she got on a train headed to
new york city
the recorder missing is their problem
put her in the train she came to the
city i don't know where she is
he was
the last person to see kathy
alive
he
lied to police investigators
then you went to the mayor's
yeah so i told the police i was hoping
that would just make everything go away
mayor they took her to the train station
went all the way to sleep i said
i called her
she answered over the phone
and that puts her in the city
you know that you're telling them
something that's alive
there's also the matter of what exactly
happened that night between the couple
we didn't have a fight wrestle moved in
but you did tell me uh in our last
conversation that
that you did have an official
qualification that night
are you sure i told you that right
don't know that you're comfortable lying
is appropriate yes
there are several factors that
contributed to the fact that he did not
get arrested
the detective who received the case
michael struck
he made a series of major mistakes and
lapses in judgment
including not following through on lies
that robert durst told him
there's something else to consider about
kathy's disappearance or rather
someone else
if i thought about doing something like
that i can't imagine doing it
coming up what susan berman allegedly
did that may have led to her own death
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
that's where i read i read that they
figured that susan we were murderer
the guy obviously was friendly enough to
get up and given back over
in 2000 a woman named susan berman is
found murdered in her los angeles home a
gunshot wound to the back of her head
years later her friend real estate air
robert durst sat down for separate
interviews with documentary producers
and an la prosecutor named john lewin in
their discussion of berman's death they
revisit another mysterious moment in
durst's life when his wife kathy
mccormick durst vanished in 1982.
there's one odd aspect to kathy's
disappearance that may connect these two
women
you know about the call to the dean
right that call was a big problem for
new york because they're going wait if
kathy is dead how can she be calling
the day after durst claims he dropped
kathy off at a train station in
westchester so she could travel into new
york city the dean of kathy's medical
school received a call from someone
claiming to be kathy saying she was ill
and couldn't come in for rotations
i don't think cathy galt
do you know who i think called any
guesses the movie and
andrew was under the opinion it was
susan berman
okay she would have said no
kathy durst would never have called the
dean
of the school
and she would never have complained of
cramps abdominal problems and diarrhea
susan
would always complain of her gastric
problems
if susan berman really covered up a
potential crime for durst then why is
she dead
susan berman was killed in december of
2000
two months earlier the westchester
district attorney's office was reopening
the investigation into kathy durst's
disappearance
and
that really spooked robert durst
susan told me
that she'd been contacted by
los angeles detectives
and new york detectives
and
they want to come talk to me
susan berman was killed because she was
a witness
susan berman became a threat to him
and his livelihood
that wasn't true
they had not contacted her
did you know what i just told you or no
is that a new piece no i did not know
that they had not contacted no
susan lied to you about that
i think that susan was trying to subtly
squeeze you for money
susan would make a threat to anyone and
she was in desperate financial shape
he was her main man in that regard
we know that you flew out here san
francisco on december 19th
i think bob that that you drove down
to los angeles
killed susan i do back
you know
you don't take red-eye flights very
often did you know that
very infrequently and usually you don't
buy your tickets right at the counter
would you agree
usually i make reservations right
on december 23rd
you end up
buying that ticket
at 10 at night
at the counter in san francisco
just doesn't make sense
yeah yeah yeah i hear you i hear you
i'm just not going to be able to answer
that because i just okay hardest
he gets there just before she is killed
and he leaves right after she is killed
and he has a plane ticket in his own
name
there's one piece of evidence unlike
anything else
after berman was murdered a letter was
sent to the beverly hills police
department the letter postmarked the day
before police discovered berman's body
was imprinted with berman's address and
the word cadaver
you're writing a note to the police
that only the killer could have written
it's the misspelling of the word beverly
that's particularly strange
in durst's conversation with the
producers of the jinx he's confronted
with a different letter he wrote to
berman
1527
so obviously i want to ask you about the
cadaver note
save the spelling
or either writing looks similar and the
spelling is the same so i can see the
conclusion the cops before
so
i guess the question is did you write
the cadaver notes
and can you tell me which one of these
you wrote or which one you didn't write
no
up next robert durst ends up leaving new
york and he finds himself in texas but
his plans
soon lead to death
you're not going to go and try to cut
through the
bone like i did which was hard
i hated being a fugitive i was the worst
fugitive the world has ever met
back in the early 2000s eccentric real
estate air robert durst had a problem
in new york an investigation was
reopened into the disappearance of his
missing wife kathy mccormick durst in
california he had been linked to the
murder of his best friend susan berman
an alleged witness to the suspected
killing of kathy in order to escape
media attention he decided to move to
texas but his troubles don't end there
he
moved to galveston texas
disguised as a woman named dorothy
signer he rented an apartment
across the way from him in another
apartment was a guy named morris black
robert durst and morris black ended up
spending a lot of time together
yet things began to sour between durst
and black and on one fateful night an
argument between the two turned deadly
morris get out of here i don't ever want
to see you again
he takes the gun out i grabbed him and
the gun and we fall down in the kitchen
the gun goes off and shoots into the
side of the face
robert durst shot and killed morris
black he claimed he acted in
self-defense
but is that true
robert durst began to let his guard down
he told
morris black about janine pirro's
investigation it gave morris black the
knowledge specifically of what robert
durst was running from
that
became a huge
piece of evidence of robert durst's
motive for killing morris black
particularly as the evidence came out
that morris black was starting to jam up
robert durst for money what went through
your mind
i can't go to the police
my neighbor
is lying on the kitchen floor
oh and by the way i'm a rich guy from
new york
and my first wife disappeared
i'm going to have to dismember this body
robert durst was arrested
for
the murder of morris black
after morris black's body parts were
found on the beach of galveston
cutting somebody up with a saw
is a really difficult thing to do
i agree and you've done that now twice
correct i'm not gonna go there okay okay
okay all right one
okay okay i gotta ask
in his explosive trial in 2003 for the
murder of morris black durst took the
stand and admitted he chopped up the
body but argued he killed black in
self-defense a claim that was hard to
refute given there was a critical piece
of evidence missing
most body parts of him were found in
plastic bags except one a kind of
important one the head because it is the
head where robert durst said he shot
morris black in self-defense now if the
prosecution have morris black's complete
body they would be able to tell whether
or not that was the truth or not
the jury ended up a quitting durst of
murder
i think some of the jurors were swayed
by his celebrity and his wealth
i have to give credit to the defense
team they did an outstanding job
even though the prosecution didn't do
all that they could i think there still
was enough there circumstantially to
prove his guilt
durst wound up pleading guilty to bail
jumping and evidence tampering charges
and would also violate the terms of his
parole
after spending some time behind bars
durst was released and would go on
living as a free man
yet durst's life would change forever in
2015.
what made you do do the movie
still sort of putting that together in
my own mind
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the law on crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
did not kill him by this
dismembering after he was dead
in 2003 after a texas jury acquitted
robert durst of murdering his neighbor
morris black and spending some time
locked away on other charges the real
estate air was ultimately released soon
after
despite circumstantial evidence that
durst may have murdered his best friend
susan berman and was perhaps involved in
the disappearance of his first wife
kathy mccormick durst durst was not
criminally charged in either case
yet beginning in 2010
durst did something odd
i can't tell you how much i appreciate
you're
sitting here and going through parts of
your life with me i enjoy doing it
durst agreed to a series of interviews
that would eventually be produced into a
documentary entitled the jinx which
would air on hbo in 2015.
i believe that at the heart of robert
durst's cooperation in the documentary
series that became the jinx
was
another film
called all good things
all good things was a fictionalized
story
about the robert durst saga written by
mark smirling it was directed by andrew
jarecki
robert durst apparently read the script
he wanted to reach out to andrew jarecki
and see the film
and this made me feel bad about the
movie andrew i mean the idea that i
could kill igor
i don't like
his major complaint about the film was
that it depicted him killing his dog
igor and yet the fact that the film
implies that he killed three human
beings didn't seem to pay him any mind
while durst would say some controversial
and arguably incriminating statements
there was one moment on the documentary
that changed everything
at one point durst goes to the bathroom
yet he doesn't realize he's on a hot mic
of
i certainly think the bathroom
confession was an actual confession he
likes to talk he likes to sell a story
he thinks that he can gain information
and then he can spin his story
not realizing that finally he was giving
information on a microphone
this alleged bathroom confession was
broadcast to the country on the series
finale of the jinx
and that's not even the most shocking
part
on the eve of
the episode of the jinx airing
he was arrested in new orleans louisiana
on suspicion of illegal possession of a
firearm possession of marijuana
and it was believed that he was going to
fly to cuba
there are lots of things that i know
um
and and i know it's tough and i'm
guessing right now you're probably
nervous is that right
and scary i mean it's you know this is a
terrible place to be
the interview you've been watching of
durst and la prosecutor john lewin
occurred right after durst was arrested
in louisiana
the tapes from this interrogation and
the jinx would prove to be critical
pieces of evidence in a brand new case
spearheaded by lewin
i do cold murder cases
complex circumstantial murder cases
probably 90 of the cases that i do the
person that i'm sitting across from
they're like you that case was the
people versus robert durst
after 15 years the real estate heir was
officially charged with first degree
murder for the killing of susan berman
this is really the case that never ends
hopefully it won't end until justice is
achieved
there's been so many things that have
happened i mean this is just the most
unusual
situation ever
john lewin is putting it all together
and making it all
make sense i mean there's there's all
these different parts
but they're all connected and they all
all mean something and i think
i think by the end of this trial
everyone's gonna really understand
everything that's happened
that's part one of the robert durst saga
and there is so much more in our part
two episode there are moments that we
haven't shown you yet from his police
interrogation that may leave you shocked
but not only that there's robert durst's
murder trial little preview he took the
stand testified for 15 days and had a
back and forth with prosecutor john
lewin that was something straight out of
a movie so that's all we have for you
right now on prime crime leave us your
comments on instagram and twitter with
the hashtag primecrime as always thank
you for joining us and until next time
be safe
[Music]
you